a white former police officer faces a
murder charge this morning for shooting
a black woman inside her Texas home Erin
Dean posted bond overnight following his
arrest late yesterday he resigned
earlier in the day before he could be
fired from the Fort Worth Police
Department Dean shot 28 year old Tatyana
Jefferson as he was responding to a
neighbor's call for a wellness check
Omar Villafranca is outside Fort Worth
police headquarters Omar good morning
how are the victim's family reacting to
this murder charge
the family is relieved that the officer
was arrested and charged with murder but
they're quick to say that this is not
just about the officer but the way the
Fort Worth police department trains
their officers and we talked to a former
Fort Worth cop who agrees and says the
department needs to change as a black
female former police officer I'm afraid
when I get stopped former Fort Worth
police officer LaRhonda Young says she
doesn't trust the department's officers
and she feels
twenty-eight-year-old that Tatiana
Jefferson's death represents a clear
breach of protocol officers are shooting
before assessing situations if that
officer had simply knocked on the door
that young lady would be alive today
officer Aaron Dean resigned yesterday
body cam footage shows the moment he
shot and killed Jefferson in her home on
Saturday the video shows Dean who's now
charged with murder never identified
himself as a police officer Clark he was
responding to a 2:00 a.m. wellness call
from Jefferson's neighbor but interim
Police Chief Ed Krause said it may not
have been clear there was no emergency
if they thought they had something more
criminal Jefferson's siblings Ashley in
a Darius car say it's a sign the
department has to change what their
attorney called a brutal culture of
policing no gun should even been out
there was no threat when you heard the
gunshot came through a window what was
your response
that's drive-by material Police Chief
Krause agrees there's no excuse for
Dean's actions what can you tell members
of the community who have told us
incidents like this are why'd they do
not trust Fort Worth police I tell them
and get it we're trying to ensure that
they act and react for the servant's
heart instead of a warrior's heart Dean
was charged with murder but the
investigation will not stop there in
fact Fort Worth city officials have
handed over a preliminary case to the
FBI to look into possible civil rights
violations we are expecting an update on
the criminal case later on this morning
Anthony such an upsetting story Omar
thank you